released almost 20 years ago jeepers
creepers is a classic horror movie and
it's even spawned two sequels
like any good scary film it can still
induce hair-raising fear
years later so here's a recap on what
makes it one of a kind
jeepers creepers follow siblings darius
gary jenner and patricia trish jenner
who begin the movie on a road trip home
from college
they're on spring break in rural florida
on a country highway
with time on their hands and taking the
scenic route to where they're going so
the scary movie setup is
perfect unfortunately for darry and
trish they don't take the quicker way
home
which means they cross paths with a
mysterious demonic creature
before they know it a rusty ominous
looking truck starts tailgating darry
and trish
it's a subtle nod to another ominous
truck that made its appearance in the
1971 steven spielberg directed tv movie
duel
in that movie star dennis weaver was in
the sights of an
unseen driver behind the wheel of a
massive dangerous peterbilt 281
in the case of jeepers creepers the
audience finds out pretty quickly that
the driver of this truck
is a strange creature called the creeper
he's not human and he can fly
fast which we find out after tris starts
questioning his movements
wondering how someone can loot their car
and get back and forth to the church
where the creeper keeps his victims in
such record time trish eventually takes
a guess
maybe he can leap to all buildings in a
single bound yes the creeper can fly
unlike many movie monsters though the
creeper doesn't just come out at night
he not only drives but also appears to
do his business during all hours of the
day
darry and trish first see the creeper
dumping bodies at the abandoned
church that's conveniently located in
plain view of the road
not only do they see this strange figure
unloading corpses into a large pipe that
sticks out of the ground
but they get a clear full frontal shot
of the creeper after he spots them
watching him
in most monster movies the monster
doesn't usually fight on equal terms
monsters stick to their strengths
vampires for example do their monster
mashing at night
and for obvious reasons as sunlight is
one of their biggest weaknesses
however the creeper doesn't have that
limitation he isn't afraid to roam free
and wreak havoc during the daytime
after the creeper sees darry and trish
watching him he proceeds to get in his
truck and chase after them
he rams into their car several times
until their vehicle goes off the side of
the road
and then he speeds off into the distance
at this point in the movie
the creeper is only trying to scare the
siblings so they could have presumably
gone on their way
mostly unscathed but darry decides to be
a hero
darry convinces his sister to go back to
the church to see what the creeper is
throwing down the pipe
after all bloodstained sheets that are
shaped like human bodies could be
anything right
wrapped in a sheet wrapped and roped in
a sheet
wrapped and roped in a sheet with red
stains on it
darry hears something coming from the
pipe so he has his sister hold his feet
as he tries to get a better view of what
lurks below
he sees rats and freaks out trish lets
go of his legs and he falls into the
pipe
finding an underground tomb filled with
bodies and one poor victim who's still
barely alive but on his way out i found
our body
what i found
it's the creepers hideout also referred
to as the house of pain
instead of helping darry find a way out
trish does as he orders and leaves him
to fend for himself so she can try to
flag down a passing car
but against all odds darry makes it out
their car starts
and they drive away even at this point
darry and trish could probably have left
this freaky town and called for help
once they were out of harm's way
but darry of course wants justice for
the lifeless victims he's found
so they go to a nearby diner to contact
the authorities
this unfortunately gives the creeper
more time to find out that someone
discovered his lair
with all signs pointing to darry and
trish it also leaves the door open for
the creeper to discover that darry and
trish are in possession
of something he needs after finding the
bodies and linking them to the creeper
the siblings contact local authorities
to solve a case involving hundreds of
dead people
stuck up on the walls like some psycho
version of the sistine chapel
as they get in deeper darry and trish
actually take pretty logical steps to
deal with the monster
and that's saying something for a horror
movie a genre that routinely sees the
characters do the exact opposite of what
they should do
even after the first cops to respond or
killed by the creeper the siblings drive
to an old woman's house and asked to
call the police
caught in the crosshairs the creeper
kills the woman escaping to their
vehicle
darry and trish momentarily hurt the
creeper by running him over
by now they've seen this inhuman face
and know he can fly
so it wouldn't have been out of the
ordinary for them to stop seeking help
from the authorities
in typical horror movie logic dick takes
here that darry and trish go rogue
without consulting the police anymore
thinking that no one else would believe
their tail i'm being chased by a guy who
likes to
pull tongues on his severed heads with
his teeth special extension for that
but instead they doggedly press on and
go to a police station
trying again to alert local law
enforcement this inadvertently involves
them in hearing about what a lady sees
in her psychic dreams
darry and trish first find out what the
creeper is because of a random phone
call
while they're in the diner an unknown
woman calls them on a payphone that
happens to be right next to them
the woman somehow knows who they are and
the danger that lies ahead
she tells them that if they hear the
song jeepers creepers they need to run
away as fast as possible
only after they arrive at the police
station does the audience discover who
the woman is
a psychic named giselle gay hartman
giselle tells them that the creature is
an
ancient being that awakens every 23rd
spring for 23 days to feast on the
living
the creeper eats human body parts that
then become part of him
finding his victims by smelling their
fear there's something he can
smell something that tells it if there's
anything inside someone that it might
like and he's found something he wants
from trish and dary
the creeper not only cannibalizes
victims but is also
virtually impossible to kill case in
point trish runs over the creeper
multiple times with a car
you think he's dead they never are
the creeper momentarily appears
mutilated and dead but then a wing
sprouts up from the creeper and the
siblings drive off in fear
they have no clue what they're dealing
with but they're not going to stick
around to find out
the creeper follows trish and dary to
the police station and rejuvenates
himself by eating prisoners body parts
so while the creeper can be hurt at
least in his first film in the series he
can't be killed
that makes jeepers creepers even more
terrifying
since the only way to defeat the creeper
is to survive his 23 days of terror
darry never stood a chance the movie
takes its name from the 1938 song
jeepers creepers but the song itself
isn't just the title of the movie
it also plays a significant sinister
role in the story
after giselle plays it for darry and
trish on the phone she gives them an
ominous warning to run whenever it's
played
they hear it again in their car then
gisele sings it at the police station
jeepers creepers where'd you get those
people perhaps most maddening of all the
song plays at the end of the movie
during the big reveal
since the creeper is attracted to
specific humans and will stop at nothing
until he gets what he desires
the song's lyrics are decidedly sadistic
when paired with jeepers creepers the
movie
the lyrics in fact foreshadow darry's
fate
jeepers creepers has a memorable ending
easily forgotten over time
and unfortunately only one of the two
main characters survive
trish in a last-ditch effort to save her
brother tries sacrificing herself
telling the creeper to take her instead
because she's stronger
the creeper contemplates her offer but
then flies off into the night with dary
trish lives on to tell her story but
darry perishes at the end of jeepers
creepers in a brutal death
darry isn't shown again until the
graphic ending in which his eyes are
missing
the creeper as if he's posing for the
camera stands on the other side of darry
and
looks through the holes in darry's face
the creeper's eyes have presumably been
replaced with darys
disturbingly making darry's eyes appear
to look through the holes of where they
once were
not only does the creeper survive the
first installment it ends on an
outright sinister note with no hope in
sight a defeated and emotionally drained
trish leaves the police station
not knowing if she'll ever see her
brother again it's fair to assume that
she knows she's already lost him
as there's no way of finding the creeper
and he can't be killed
and of course the final scene of the
movie features the creeper still alive
and peacefully working in his new lair
now with darry's eyes and his own head
it's no wonder jeepers creepers haunts
people's dreams to this day this isn't a
movie you forget because of how
long ago it came out more like a movie
you forget because the ending is the
stuff of nightmares
and you choose not to remember check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one